what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we're gonna watch
brooklyn nine-nine episode nine hey hey
nine nine nine until we get to episode
99. guys
at the moment only two episodes are
partially blocked so we're doing good
we're doing it we're making progress
and in a couple weeks from now those
episodes will be back unblocked it'll be
amazing
if you enjoy our video hit the like
button subscribe and click that bell
if you wanna as well as always
full-length watch-alongs where you sync
up with the time code for b99 or over
our patreon page and over there we cover
a whole bunch of shows with the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs
included and i just really want to watch
this it's been uh you would not believe
the the stupidest struggles i've been
dealing with they're not even like
mental emotions it's all car related
and they've taken so much time that i
could just use a good laugh today so i'm
very much looking forward to this and as
always thank you to pratham jindal for
editing these highlights down for us you
rock buddy
love you rock you rock you rock
a virus got on the server and sent all
of us an email with everyone's search
histories
check this out sergeant jeffords search
the internet for
undiscovered muscle i was working out
and saw a muscle in my shoulder i'd
never seen before
i thought it might have been a
scientific discovery
you searched for cheapest date possible
and i wear that search like a badge of
honor
so ready for dinner here we go oh
would you like something sweet or maybe
savory
apple pie and i'm stuck i took olivia to
mcdonald's on our first date
dude what did you get though when i ate
meat
yeah i got a lot more than you want to
eat on the first date
i told her you need to go home
you need to pass those fries
no i can't believe sal's is gone this
place is an institution
it's the best pizza in the neighborhood
oh eighth best
oh no heads up fire marshall
oh good they do not get along with
anyone pat an oswald
of course what are you doing here you
nimrod uh there was a fire
big question is what are you doing here
what did somebody call in a missing
donut actually someone reported they
couldn't find your head but we found it
it was up your butt
you're a fireman you should know how to
treat that burn yo
oh nice it's too bad we all can't be as
awesome
as new york's finest which by the way
sounds like my mom describing her
dishware
which and she's dead so let's tread
lightly on the response that's not fair
not fair why'd you do a search for magic
theme
singles night my last four dates were
really boring so i thought i'd mix
things up
why are you responsible oh wow
no why were you looking for real estate
in ropesburg new jersey
robesburg pd offered me a job as their
new police captain no
i turned it down oh okay you
oh captain oh oh
golly super cool
fire marshal boone is incapable of
conducting a crime investigation
all fire marshals are doofuses but boone
is king doofus of doofus island
gasoline i'm pretty sure that's water
only one way to tell there were more
ways to tell
[Laughter]
here's the mope who hacked our computer
system his mother turned him in
his name is corey park why'd you target
us with your computer virus corey i
don't know i was bored and it was easy
to break into your weak-ass system
if it's so easy for this gentleman to
break into our system we may need to
hire a new i.t
director why don't you and gina get
together on that i doubt i'll need
gina's help
i'm sure she's busy anyway she knows all
the hackers man
and i'll be hacking into my stuff analog
hack boon reconsidered once you take a
look at the files
all right fine it's not a file bro it's
a donut because you're cops
all right i don't care if it's not our
jurisdiction we're solving this
it's good to see a cell i'm so sorry
about the fire yeah i can't believe it's
gone jakey
all of it the fire department's been
asking a lot of questions
they think i torched my own place can
you think of anybody who might have done
it
i could think of ten pizzerias that want
me out of the game that jerk mario comes
to mind
rising fast you might have wanted to
move up the ladder of one foodie weirdos
personal pizza email blast
[Laughter]
weird they just offered you captain
without considering anyone else
like scully because he's got so many
years on the force okay
i think i put my gun in one of these
boxes and i don't know when
mario does pine needs work good
consistency on the crust but the cheese
of sauce ratio it's a travesty
if you have to spit in a word yes
amateurs go tasting they fill up and
they lose their palate by the third
slice
that pizza looks amazing i know watch
this on an empty stomach
meanwhile over at salz it was a bunch of
smiling faces and happy stomachs
one night you snapped a little gasoline
a little match
and poof no more cells how right am i
the night of the fire is that my
father's funeral
do you know this pizza is much better
than last time
you've always ranked dead last
instructional integrity and sauce
but way more importantly and it turns
out you did six months in prison for a b
e the night of the fire i was at the
prison given a motivational speech on
how parolees can turn their lives around
well it's good to hear that the system
works and you are welcome
this is a dead end we gotta check out
that crime scene can't firemen locked it
down
grab your spitbucket boyle those hose
monkeys can't stop us
you must be simon walker have a seat
query
what's your favorite jay-z song i'm
sorry
favorite jay-z song she's kidding
no i'm not what is it i don't know i'm
sorry about her
but seriously what's your favorite jesus
i don't know big pippin
it's big pippin wrong answer friend
i'm really nervous there's no need to be
nervous yeah we're all just
calm cool collected
everything taken from the garden
apartment tv computer
stereo uh-oh spelling error
it's not very captain e geez
i just think that you meant stereo not
stereo did you mean stereo
captain that's it get in my car now and
if you say another word i promise you
you will regret it aye aye aye aye aye
okay
i'll i'll go i'm going these firemen are
not moving
we gotta distract them tell them your
little boy's cat got stuck up in a tree
i need more backstory
first off gonna be my daughter's cat
okay but if you get made because of that
it's on you
fine short hair calico the sun is
adopted your wife is in a coma
oh that's brutal i like it make sure to
mention all that
guys i i really need your help my little
boy brian
my angel i bought him a short-haired
calico after my wife fell into a coma
motorcycle crash kind of looks like you
handsome guy
brian was adopted so his abandonment
issues just struck out
t-ball last week everyone called him
crying brian oh
no crying brian hello peralta
what's going on sir what's going on is
that peralta has screwed with me
for the last time and now he's gonna pay
oh you know what boone anytime you want
to give him oh whoa
oh that is
oh
[Music]
don't tell me what to tell people what
to do well make me not do it tough guy
oh no oh no no
oh no i apologize marshall boone for
detective peralta's actions i'm a
reasonable man so
i'm just gonna say this fire peralta
immediately
he started a fight he overstepped his
jurisdiction and he's obsessed with his
pizza place
what i'm obsessed with is how you're
bungling this investigation oh they
should write a song about it called
welcome to the bungle
why is it special because it's the best
pizza in the neighborhood well
according to charles's email blast it's
actually number eight uh captain reads
my class
of course is the only one that measures
mouthfeel
[Laughter]
when i was a kid i was short stop by my
little league team oh my gosh
that's the truth it's not a brag dad was
the coach and after every game he would
take the team to sal's
halfway through our last season he left
me and my mom
and the worst part about it was that i
couldn't go with him to sals anymore
well that's
certainly not what i expected this to be
about
i'm sorry that happened to you i mean
what kind of dad just
does lisa's son like that
you and i we're gonna solve this thing
together
okay okay okay first let's hug like man
[Laughter]
get in here miss diaz are you here to
reconsider
we bought the deputy's bullets like you
suggested hi sergeant
no i'm still not interested at all but
this is detective santiago she's one of
our top detectives
and she really wants the job i uh
yes can i ask what happened to the last
captain he quit
to start a carpet cleaning business
because that was better than being
captain here because this is the most
boring place
on earth she doesn't mean that
it's okay it's true gotta be known for
something
oh i know that guy's name sandy forster
who do you think i should hire well the
interviews
got a little off try but i'd go with
simon walker
that guy no way he yelled at me when i
asked him the same question about jay-z
three times in a row
why does that matter because whoever
takes this it job is gonna have to deal
with hitchcock asking how to log into
his email
every single day forever what about this
guy
no he was scared of everything do you
remember rosa's reaction last time the
printer jammed
i'll pay for that we already have the
perfect candidate already
savant that punk who hacked us turn your
greatest weakness
into your greatest strength savant tore
our walls down but he can build them
back
up his mom ratted him out so i bet he'd
love a steady paycheck to get out of
that snitch's house
got a mic right now well done gina
good gina hire the criminal
any reason you can think of one of your
guys would have forced this cabinet open
while they're putting the fire out
no no i can't looks like it was jimmy
open with a crowbar
oh my god i know who did it come on
kid cody did it again hey cut his back
do you want to take the pole down
oh my god yes
let justice be served did you get it
uh-huh my turn nope no time
oh we know you burned down sales gino
you hated him because his pizza was
better than yours that's not true
gino's pizza's always been the tastiest
wrong according to boyle's email blast
it was downright lousy before
that's what made it so suspicious when
he suddenly loved it
crust was charred the cheese was stringy
and flavorless
but the sauce all motto on the sod
and that was your mistake you didn't
just burn sals down you also stole his
secret sauce recipe
here's a picture of the cabinet in which
said recipe was held
busted open with a crowbar your
so-called motivational speech down at
the prison ended at 5 p.m
leaving you plenty of time to get back
to salz and burn it to the ground
so i guess there's only one thing left
to say gino mia
you're under arrest do you mind
i actually did all the work see i knew
you would find you know what fine
gina b nutri under arrest for arson yes
very mature
off we do you never would have taken
that job so why'd you even care that
they offered it to me
i can't help it i'm competitive i have
seven brothers and i was the only girl i
always had to fight for a place at the
table well you're not the only girl at
the table anymore
we work in a police force full of dudes
we gotta have each other's backs okay
you saying you have my back yeah i got
your back don't smile i'm still mad at
you
i thought we were having a moment
moment's over shut up yeah
women bonding all right all i have to do
is put my thumb on that thing and it
opens up all my electric mails
you seem real smart man oh look and you
play with toys
you're part of the nine-nine now we look
after each other if savant was to do
anything to harm this precinct would i
destroy them
answer uncertain try again
i see we are once again at war with the
fire department you are not to retaliate
oh i wouldn't dream of it sir in fact
i'm gonna send over a little peace
offering
some of sal's famous sauce now boyle
[Music]
fire fire fire
[Laughter]
run charles
i want a just a big old bucket
i just want to scoop it into mine how'd
they get the pool around the pole
oh my god well i get yeah i guess they
had to have like
cut a hole in it and then cauterized the
hole
after the fact or something
very impressive yeah they do it so
quietly
i don't know they didn't wake anybody
they got the sauce
yeah they have to carry the sauce in
like in little increments to fill it up
or do they have just like a big old
sauce drone you think they would have
been detected yeah
yeah that fire department doesn't have
very good security
but then again that's not their job so
maybe we could just crash a fire station
let's talk about let's do it kick it off
john i
was delighted once more by brooklyn
nine-nine
uh yeah i don't know i mean this feels
like a very sort of natural comedic
trope to pull into this setup if you got
comedic cops there's got to be some kind
of rivalry agency or
you know other organization for them to
be at odds with so it makes perfect
sense that it would be new york's
bravest uh but yeah i thought that was
really funny i thought uh
patton oswalt is like the perfect
character actor to bring in
for that i'm kind of surprised there
wasn't more joey diaz just because you
know he does comedy and stuff too
but uh yeah he's never been
controversial ever either
oh no that's right that's right now is
the time
to to to wish for more joey diaz
yeah there was a clip going around on
joey diaz on joe rogan show from years
ago
oh just this year this clip started
going around oh good
what was in the clip well it is just
too kind to mention oh yeah and said it
sounds
like video it sounds like the kind of
thing that was
inviting for all just too inclusive
too tolerant not too woke
this is a no woke says woke free zone
good
stuff but joey diaz yeah yeah it's true
he doesn't do that everything he didn't
did
anything funny in here either literally
every other pizza chef they talk to has
at least one more scene or moment than
he did like yeah
just in the office you know giving his
little deposition i like pat and oswalt
uh he i'm very charmed by him and i
i've only recently started listening to
his stand-up comedy
um i've seen him like a lot in shows and
movies and
interviews surprisingly but never really
his comedy but i've heard some of his
actual stand-up comedy lately and he's a
really funny guy
let's see why he's so well known so yeah
having him in here and this is
his chemistry bouncing off of andy
samberg was really good
uh i love the chemistry between
um rosa and
and uh amy yeah i love their chemistry
a lot and while i did enjoy this episode
i did think it was actually the weaker
one out of all the ones we've seen so
far
yeah i didn't find it to be uh as
funny as it wasn't as hysterical yeah
while they had its moments that were
really funny
like for sure that it's like it's a
comedy show all right
my favorite show of all time is friends
and i'm not like in stitches every
freaking episode you know
i can't say that about every comedy
gonna be better than others
yeah yeah exactly you know you can't
expect them to knock it out of the park
a hundred percent
every time or be as endeared in a heart
felt away every time or whatever um
it's just kind of been on this like this
up ramp
for all all the episodes it's just been
better better better better better and
then this one was like okay this one
didn't
go better it's not bad it's still really
good
uh it just didn't uh hit me in the
laughs as hard
but there were still some really funny
moments yeah
i'm not sure what it is that's kind of
mid it's kind of weird to like
criticize comedy about that because i'm
also so forgiving when i know it's a
sitcom that has 24 episodes they got to
be funny all the time
yeah yeah well yeah it's one of those
things where i feel like as long as it
doesn't dip
out of being still enjoyable and
fun spending time with your ensemble
yeah it's like this one wasn't one of
the better ones that we've seen thus far
however yeah it was like still
there's only like 300 more episodes ago
i feel like i'm damn damning of the
faint praise by saying
he's perfectly passable because like
yeah it was fun
still like i really did like get having
amy and rosa paired off
you know like there could have been more
substance to that but i just thought
their interplay that that made way for
was a lot of fun to watch and especially
to the interplay
i always love it but you know between uh
boyle and peralta especially
like when you get an ensemble yeah like
this where
you know a lot of the time boyle is the
butt of a joke so when you get a
character like that into a situation
where it's like oh but there's a part of
this that's exactly their element
and so like him with all the pizza and
stuff like that and the recurring
oh the whole thing is like really what
it has he's reading
he's dealing with his mouth yeah it's
like that like that
was my favorite recurring joke yeah the
whole newsletter thing like just
becoming
more of a big deal than at least we
would think it is because we're with
sort of andy sandberg's
pov for a lot of these i actually
thought the cleverest moment out of this
whole thing was seeing that gina had
really sharp intentions for why she was
handling
the um because it's like they're
interviewing people but she handles it
kind of like an interrogation
yeah uh and so i really loved the reveal
there of why she was doing that like she
didn't have sarcastic reasoning to do it
she had sincere meaning
behind each one of the annoying choices
that she was
putting on so i was like the montage of
that was like kind of funny um
you know where it's going i didn't see
the reveal coming of
why she's doing what she's doing yeah
like you know where it's going that
they're gonna want to hire the ig kid
yeah like that that was awesome all
these dudes are gonna be dweebs who
aren't right for the job yeah
yeah yeah uh but um i i would actually
really love the whole thing with like
holt being able to see that gene is
valuable
you guys just don't see it you don't
give it a credit and then come to find
out like oh yeah she has some good
reasoning behind
why yeah so that to me was the cleverest
moment of them all but you still get
character nuances here and i appreciate
whenever you get a little bit of that
more of santiago finding about her
brothers and then her
competitiveness peralta having this
history with his father
and like a very core memory associated
with his pizza place
that's how i feel about if my denny's
burnt down or if my pizza guy burned
down
the place i go to pizza guy uh used to
go there every sunday
with my family after church and
it's near right near where john lives
and literally it's like
i used to go there uh every sunday
and um there was a few years i didn't go
but now because now it's like a 15-20
minute drive for me to go
uh whereas before like five minutes so
and that makes a big difference in life
because you've always got a veteran
three times as long i'm not doing that
it's hard
as long as you never know like trapping
my pick up that parking lot might be
busy
i don't want to deal with that now you
need your own newsletter of the best
pizza places in tarzan
so i i've got but recently i went back
there
i started going back a couple weeks ago
and the second i went back hadn't seen
this guy in years and
it was when we were still wearing masks
all the time when we had to go out
and he recognized me and i hadn't been
there in so long
it's so long yeah family he's family
he's asking about my family and then
i've been going like every other week
again since so yeah i
have like a pizza place that's like a
mom-and-pop pizza place shop
so i'm really endeared to that storyline
because i
i relate to that on personal level like
i don't have like a chain that i'm
my family's married to but uh there is
a place called pizza guy where i'm like
the owner mike and every time i see him
how's your family
how's your wife how's your kids you know
like really really talking it's like
delicious pizza i love introducing
people to it so
yeah if you guys are in california go to
studio city valley village and go to
pizza guy
and it is delicious pack the place
they've been around here for 30 years
so needless to say i've given all this
description to be like i really
clicked with that moment because i
imagine a lot of people in new york
probably have that considering there's
so many
like we got a lot out here a lot of mom
and pop pizza places as do most places
in america
but new york especially has a lot of
pizza places
so i feel like that's a very um you know
probably a very sentimental thing for a
lot of people who really like
live and like have live in new york you
know yeah
um it seems like having like a a lexicon
of good and bad pizza is a new york
requirement
yeah you could be from that area or or
move there you gotta
like refine your pizza palette and i
kind of wish they didn't end on their
back to being competitive with each
other
yeah it would it would be nice to just
let that growth solidify or something or
or
yeah not be so forward in that we're
gonna reset the dynamic now
yeah yeah i like the shift and dynamic a
lot with them yeah and i could see and
not that this
wouldn't happen if they bring that
character back and if they got patent i
have to imagine they will bring that
character back at some point but i feel
like if you if you left it in a softer
place that could a still have been funny
and b yeah
like leave the dynamic open a bit more
for not knowing exactly what's gonna
happen to the dynamics once pat and
oswald and the firefighters come in you
know
very true but i do love that opening
joke a lot of
uh of uh terry
being like animated a scientific
discovery
like he just helped me through a new
muscle discovered
like he's just so buff that you found it
he's like he's so strong above elephants
developing
discovered muscles i think that's
hilarious if anyone's gonna do that it's
gonna be
such a funny joke it's a really funny
joke
uh all right guys well brooklyn nine
nine
uh again yeah it's uh it's still real
that's fine it's still a really good
episode
uh leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and hey
let's do a
john you wanted to shout out deontay w
tongue punch fart box in a
and a box full of clocks in a box and
here it knocks
with uh moxicillin amoxicillin
uh as we flock to the stocks of
uh my i'm trying not to say dewey cox
but i did
cox you know john c reilly got top
villain
he wasn't the villain he was a hero like
deontay
deonte would be the hero of my cop movie
because think about it they called him
tongue punch fart box
like how cool of an enigmatic cop
character could he be he works alone
and his methods are unorthodox why
because once you're caught
he's gonna tongue punch you in the fart
box instead of taking you to prison
tongue punch fart box his methods are
unorthodox
dude that's part invent and then eminem
or somebody can make
the theme song yeah for box
box whatever rhymes with far bucks you
know yeah we've come up with nothing
that does nothing
at all so yeah dude
you know i want you to send me your head
shot wearing your best like
70s detective jacket and uh
you know really get into character all
right
thank you deonte you've provided us with
a lot to think about
[Music]